so before we get going on this
um when you just have a look at this
forget about the square root for a
moment are you confident to draw this
yes okay so the first thing we're going
to need to do in order to work out what
the
square root of this looks like is we
need to really understand what this
looks like and we actually have to have
a pretty decent graph of this before we
work out the what the graph of the
square root looks like in fact basically
my good graph of this will be my primary
tool for how to graph the square root
okay now you need actually something
that's a little bit better than a normal
graph like if I just told you graph f of
x full stop what kinds of features do
you think are important I might actually
note something down
okay so you're going to have to look for
asymptotes and you can already see one
right there okay what else would you
think is important
um if we were being very particular
which in this case uh it's not too
relevant because I know what kind of
graph this is going to look like I might
ask for turning points and things like
that but for now I think this is
probably enough right now usually like
once you've got these two done okay and
you put them on and you'd be fine but
because what we're asking for is the
square root I need to know a little bit
more for example an intercepts right
that basically means when x equals zero
you get your y intercepts and when y
equals zero you get your X intercepts
but in addition to that
to accurately know the shape of the
square root of this thing we also need
to know where is the graph
equal to one now that's like a weird
thing right this is like
where is the graph equal to zero right
why would you think it might be
important to know where the graph is
equal to one in relation to the square
root have I think um
very good so the square root of one
is just one and obviously if you take a
number like say suppose I gave you
something like all right I found some
other spot um you know this graph is
going to go up to really high values so
if f x equal to four
then you know that the square root of
that is just going to be 2 right in
other words when you take the square
root of a number that's bigger than one
you get smaller but if I found another
place for you and I said actually it's
closer to the axis it was something like
a quarter
think about this for a second now when
you take the square root what happens to
this
um
yeah which is a bit counterintuitive
right we're so used to square roots
being smaller than the number but
actually underneath one when you take a
square root you get bigger and so you
can see I need to know exactly where
this goes I need to know when it's equal
to one when it's above one and when it's
below one because the square root will
interact differently with those things
does that make sense so why don't we try
what I would recommend is we're going to
draw this thing first we need to draw a
good graph of it I'd encourage you to
draw it no smaller than a third of a
page now I know that is considerably
larger than what you've got there and
the reason why is because of this stuff
that I'm looking for right if you have a
think about it I'm going to draw mine
comically large up here this is a lot
bigger than a third of a page but what
we're going to be doing is we're going
to end up having
basically two graphs on here I mean one
of them we're gonna end up like if
you've got pencil there you can rub it
out but as we construct this there's
it's going to be very busy it's going to
be a lot on there okay
so do you have a fresh piece of paper
there have you got a ruler
okay so let's dry ourselves up a nice
big set of axes and let's start to chip
away at this thing
uh let's do it in the order that you
suggested so let's look for asymptotes
first because they're generally pretty
easy to identify what's the first
asymptote you can see
fantastic so I'm going to that's exactly
right but I'm going to try and encourage
you to be a little more specific with
your language it's ax equals two that
gives you that vertical asymptote and of
course it is but you're going to have
other asymptotes right that have
equations so let's actually State the
equation x equals to vertical lines
let's go ahead and put that in I'm gonna
eyeball that like so
and then I label is there another
asymptote you can tell me about
um y equals okay so there's a horizontal
asymptote and it comes from here can you
just unpack for me how did you know that
there was going to be a um a horizontal
one as well as a vertical one uh because
the formula tell me what the formula is
explain that to me
a over x minus
wait sorry uh H and then you've got like
a plus whatever on the end yeah uh minus
H it doesn't actually I mean to the
matter does it but it's just a constant
but I get the idea um do you want that
to be a plus or minus
sure some cost there okay so this is I
guess we could call this this is a
general form right you know it's going
to give you a hyperbola of some kind and
then it's going to be vertically shifted
okay so that's totally fine
um I'm okay with that I mean you do get
the right result which like you said
it's y equals two so I'm going to try my
best to have like a decent your
horizontal and vertical scales don't
have to match with each other they do
have to match it themselves like if I
say that's two then this has to be
negative two
the vertical scale can actually be
different however it actually just makes
it easier for you if they're pretty
close Okay I mean sometimes you get
ridiculous graphs that gives you give
you funny numbers that you're like I
have to make them different but in this
case you're fine okay so we've got y
equals two
and that's two right there now the only
reason why I was just pausing Doris on
how you knew where the asymptote was is
um not everything is going to fit into a
generalized formula right you can
encounter lots of different equations
out there for example I could give you a
graph like this
now I'm deliberately choosing this
because there is not a generalized
formula for it but I reckon you could
make some pretty good guesses about what
it looks like and the fact that it's
actually going to have some asymptotic
Behavior even though it doesn't look
anything like this right because I think
you know what sign looks like could you
trace with your hand for me it's like
yep okay so it's this wave that goes up
and down when you divide by X as X gets
very large positive or very large
negative
you get a really massive denominator
which means the whole thing is going to
approach what
um yeah that's right if our denominator
is like a thousand a million you know
that sine X only stays between 1 and
negative one so it's like okay this is a
of a moderate size this thing's just
going to get huge so in fact what you
get is this
uh sign right okay so it's gonna look
something right
and then it's also going to have this on
the other side
now you might say mystery that doesn't
look like an asymptote to me because it
like crosses it lots and lots of times
right
um some asymptotes can be crossed and
some can't do you know which is which
if you don't it's okay I will tell you
but no not sure no yeah that's okay so
vertical asymptotes when we're talking
about like normal functions and that
kind of thing vertical asymptotes can't
be crossed because they come from
discontinuities
see how you you literally can't put two
in there it just like explodes you're
like oh can't divide by zero yeah
however and this is where the formula
helps if it doesn't tell the whole story
um
horizontal asymptotes don't have
anything to do with this continuities
right in fact I guess this one I should
have put like this has a vertical one
here so it's gonna hold on X is going to
be positive so it's going to actually
Skyrocket here this one's gonna like go
down Okay
um what's really going on is you told me
about how this gets big positive or big
negative it's really just about the
extremities of the graph which is why in
the middle you can cross as many times
as you like it's actually completely
irrelevant and you've already seen this
I actually saw on your page right if you
had a graph that looked I don't know
something like this right I don't know
weirdo thing like this
um maybe like that
and then like that you've seen things
like this before right now this clearly
has a horizontal asymptote right but in
the middle of the graph these guys don't
care about the horizontal asymptote it's
only at the
extremities at the extreme ends okay
so the way I would going back to your
formula the reason why the formula works
is because as X gets very very large
tell me what happens
to this
yeah it gets small because you've got a
concept and a constant maybe you've got
two and two and as X gets to values like
a thousand and a million those twos as
if they're not even there right they're
so unimportant so you get two over a
million well it's the answer the word we
would use that is it's trivial it's like
it's it's like it's zero okay so because
it's like zero that's why you only end
up with this thing and that's why this
is the horizontal asymptote you get okay
so it's just important you know like
formulas in general forms they're very
helpful but you should dig a little bit
to know why do they work okay
from here we've got our asymptotes
intercepts you can help me out
uh the x intercept
I mean that the y-intercept is
four I don't know three yep so uh hold
on hold on well let's let's write this
out shall we so you were just working
out the winder set so x equals zero is
going to give you let's let's put it in
shall we so F of 0 is equal to 2 over 0
minus two plus two yeah
two over negative two plus two what's
this
negative one yeah yeah plus two yeah no
relax this is a thing which happens all
the time it's because like I don't feel
bad right
um your brain is concentrating on so
many different things that even though
you're like you looked at this and you
laughed because you're like oh of course
right it's not like you don't know how
to do this but your working memory got
overloaded happens all the time what it
does mean is like there's a way to
overcome this
um when you hate making silly mistakes
for yourself we'll just do what I did
just write it out right don't worry
about doing your head you don't need to
um some people tell me some sins tell me
to write it because it takes a really
long time you know what else takes a
really long time fixing a mistake that
you don't know where it is so I think it
says you don't all right so I've got one
uh that's right there and we already
knew before that's kind of convenient
it's almost like the question was
designed to do this those parts are
important so let's just keep that in
mind uh can you help me work out a
that was a y intercepts and x-intercept
now
y equals zero
yes good you're learning the lesson
fantastic
so what have we got here is your equals
it does look like that doesn't it
because I I'm going to subtract you from
both sides I can then divide by two
yeah
um then what have I got here I've got
oh I've got to be careful that's that
is that right
that look good which matches by the way
you're like oh I'm expecting because
you've seen hyperba before uh it's not a
complicated one so you're expecting like
this kind of thing happening right okay
now this is actually very good because
um because it's not too complicated you
can kind of draw what's going on here
right so you can sort of say oh I know
I'm going to head down towards there and
this is going to head off to that hasn't
heard and you're going to get something
sort of in Reverse over here so fast so
good
now it's worth noting just before I move
on if I hadn't have given you such a
simple one if I'd put more stuff in
there if I put like an x squared or if I
had more things sometimes it Wiggles
around sometimes see how we're like
coming from underneath the asymptote
weird ones will come over the asymptote
and then approach from the top if you
want on another occasion or for a
different problem I can give you an
example of that but the point of this
problem like they've intentionally made
this simple because they really want you
to focus on this square root thing
what's going on there okay so just I
just want you to file just because
you're coming from the bottom doesn't
mean you always end up on the bottom
there's ways to work out or you end up
okay now we're going to do the square
root part this this is y equals f of x
so now what I want is y equals the
square root of that okay
now
um this part is slightly laborious but
once you get the hang of it you're like
oh I can do this instinctively but I'm
going to do it super slow to begin with
okay